what's up everyone we are back at Witte
we are now sitting down with windy
boring hello hi it's great to be here
thank you for coming I appreciate it
thank you Mary Jane's the women of weed
yeah what's not to like right women we'd
like there's so much to talk about so
much to love and you've been doing this
for a while like 12 and a half years of
experiencing directing and producing and
filmmaking and so then what was this
calling to women or weed well it it's
actually pretty funny because I was not
a cannabis user before I started the
film so I moved to Colorado in 2014 and
that was right when the legalization for
cannabis was being regulated for adult
use or recreationally used as what they
sometimes call that and people were
teasing me ahead of time like you're
gonna see a pot dispensary on every
corner like there's gonna be a big cloud
of pot smoke over Denver you know things
like that um and while that wasn't true
what I did start hearing was all of
these amazing stories of women having
success in the industry I was like well
I'm curious but you know I don't really
have an access point to that as a
storyteller yet well in 2015 I finally
heard the statistic that 36% of senior
leadership in the cannabis industry was
women and when you compare that to the
national average of 22 percent there was
something about cannabis that was
attracting more female leadership and at
that point I was curious enough to start
talking to people so I actually
interviewed a hundred people over the
phone to just kind of wrap my head
around this and I realized that cannabis
was an intersection of gender parity and
social justice and environmental
sustainability and so those three core
values had been present in all my other
work so I knew that even if I wasn't a
cannabis user I could help tell the
story to elevate the women in the
industry who were doing that work right
tell us about that intersectionality of
those three and teachers about that yeah
well it I view myself as an
intersectional feminine
right so any time I have an opportunity
to work on a project that brings
multiple viewpoints together my spidey
senses as a filmmaker like go off and
I'm like let's do that like I'm curious
I have a lot of questions and we're
bringing this together I need to I need
to figure out more by the way I heard
this definition of feminism ask women
are human it should be treated as such
yeah and I was like whoa I think
everyone can get behind that and if you
can't get behind that I mean that's
pretty telling right so I really I
really feel like as women you know we we
may be siloed into these different
things right maybe you're a woman in
cannabis a woman in tech or you know
you're a white woman or you're a woman
of color or you're this and you're that
or you a woman in the LGBTQ community
you know um but we're actually the
majority when we come out and support
each other you know we're totally we're
51 almost 52 percent of the population
and yet in film
we're 33 percent of speaking roles and
we have you know 12 percent of our
directors in big Hollywood movies are
female so here I am as a female director
doing a story about women leading a new
industry and we're able to talk about
intersectional feminism that's focusing
on on on opportunity not oppression and
it's kind of a mind-blowing thing for
people I mean I I should be forward
right and we don't necessarily need to
talk about all the terrible things that
are happening to women like yes there's
room for that but if that's the only
narrative we have like how can we really
overcome that how is that inspiring to
attract more women to come into
leadership positions it's it's not right
yeah but it's super inspiring when young
women get to watch Mary Jane's and then
they're like wow I can do it too yeah
and Geena Davis says if you can see it
you can be it you'd see it you can be it
and that's really what we tried to show
so if there's good mentorship there's
good social fabric that
exactly and so if they can set even if
it's not oh I have this went to the same
school as this person it's oh I have a
similar background to her or I you know
I'm that body type or that ethnicity or
represent that community and they're
having success in it too so I felt it
was really important if I'm going to do
this film about women in cannabis what
type of women am I gonna show so I tried
to show a broad cross-section so we have
40 women from 10 different states and
they're representing five different
segments of the cannabis industry and
then within all of that we have
different ages ethnicities religions
sexual orientation body type education
level you know like we really tried to
be strategic and analytical about who
could be in this film to help tell the
story and are we able to talk to all the
little girls and all the little boys at
home to say I might be able to do that
too when I grow up yeah that's I think
that's well let's unpack a couple things
from that the first thing is that there
is almost this strategic like you said
casting of the people that want it that
you want to highlight because it enables
everybody to see the opportunity versus
they're only being a certain person on
there then that's where that seems to be
really important to happen in the world
moving forward is to have MU everybody
that you can see it you can be it so and
everybody should um who's seeing it can
see somebody similar to them so they can
be them okay there's that and then
there's also the 40 different leaders
ten states so unpack this who are these
people give us some really interesting
examples of who they are and it's
currently in private screenings yes
so we're wrapping up our Film Festival
and conference tour
and we're like this close to being able
to announce some distribution news so
we're inviting everybody to follow us on
social media and sign up for our
newsletter so they get those
announcements ah and we're at Mary
Jane's film calm and on social media at
Mary Jane's film Facebook Twitter and
Instagram so that's how we're gonna let
everybody know Luke's in bio
thank you yeah so some of the women in
the film you know are cannabis
luminaries you know I call them my
cannabis fairy godmothers they're the
old guard who have been doing this for
decades right but probably before it was
even legal right they were involved as
activists activists to legalize it this
movement and turn it into the industry
that we know it is today right some of
the women I spoke to initially that
really enlightened me to the point that
I was able to start unpacking all of the
Dare generation just say no stuff that I
was brought up with they they were Betty
alderworth she's the executive director
of students for sensible drug policy
mm-hmm and I also spoke to Wanda James
its impact Betty quick okay so um Betty
was involved in the Colorado amendment
to legalize marijuana
so in Colorado was the first state to do
this in the United States you know a
couple hours later Washington announced
that they did it too but Colorado was
the first in this experiment and she was
really able to show me how this idea of
prohibition if we say no nobody can use
this to save the children it actually
makes it more dangerous because if kids
are gonna find it it's not gonna be lead
well it's not gonna be regulated they're
going into unsafe environments who knows
what's involved in the product you know
um and we if we regulate it cannabis
like alcohol if you want to purchase
that you have to go into a store it's
gonna be tested you have to show ID you
know like
all of these things and so it's actually
safer for children in our communities if
we're regulating it as opposed to just
keeping it back in the dark alleys right
Wanda James was another wonderful woman
to speak to she was the first African
American to own a legal dispensary in
the entire United States and she and her
husband had owned in Colorado yeah yeah
they were in Colorado and they had owned
restaurants they'd had all these other
businesses but they really viewed it as
an act of social justice to be people of
color opening a legal dispensary because
when you look at the arrest rates for
marijuana possession we know that use is
the same across races and ethnicities
and yet people of color are three point
seven times more likely to be arrested
for possession and we look at our prison
populations for you know nonviolent drug
affections offenses and they're mainly
people of color so anyone that's in jail
or prison for marijuana needs to be out
and helped and we're working on it but
that's not actually been written into
all of the laws right there may be an
opportunity to expunge somebody's
records but there hasn't been this mass
release of prisoners saying sorry you
were arrested and you've been sitting
there for 20 or 40 years and now we've
got a bunch of white people making
billions of dollars off of what you were
doing on the street corner yeah like we
haven't moved past that yet but we need
to get there so
Wanda James was really able to show me
the racist roots of the war on drugs and
you know as you start learning these
things even if you're doubting whether
you know cannabis can help you or fit
into your lifestyle like if we can just
fix these other things and in our
communities like why wouldn't we do it
yes you can make a bunch of money in tax
revenue but can't we also fix these
other things yes we can so let's do it
yep
then with the example Wanda mm-hmm that
you were just saying that is see it be
it for so many people I love that one
okay so the maybe let's unpack this in a
little bit more detail because I'm sure
you've been learning a lot about it you
you just you just showed us the tip of
the iceberg right there so everything
else that's below the surface that we
don't typically see let's talk about
that so besides the egregious amount of
people that are put into jail in prison
for for marijuana which is eight hundred
thousand times a year in the United
States eight hundred thousand times a
year people go to jail or prison for a
year yeah for cannabis that's what the
number was yeah that's a lot of people
that was me too yeah damn that's so much
lost time and potential that's like the
worst part about it there's just people
losing their freedom and then loot and
now like you said that now becomes super
profitable for corporations that are
typically run by white men ranker and if
you and if you have that on your record
you have to check it on all of your job
applications you have to check that box
the you know I've been convicted of a
felony on um housing applications I mean
this if you want to get your children
back if they've been taken away while
you were incarcerated like it just sets
up these communities to have more and
more obstacles to try to overcome this
and so this is why certain communities
and even certain states have now written
it into the legalization to expunge
people's records you know that was part
of amendment 64 in California it's
slow-going but they're still trying to
work on that and it comes down to the
local district attorney who you know it
is really are they motivated or they not
motivated to do that but Massachusetts
was really revolutionary another woman
in our film chalene title she
help draft the legalization to that went
before the voters and it included a
provision that said if you've been
convicted for marijuana you may not be
excluded from the cannabis industry and
no other state has done that before
you know Colorado didn't do that that
wasn't part of their legalization so if
you've had a drug possession you're
barred from the industry which i think
is unfair you know valuable insights
right like you've been doing it for
longer and why number one like why would
we bar anybody from this industry if
they've got a good skill right knit but
number two like you were targeted most
likely for this Aaron you probably
couldn't afford the big fancy lawyer to
get out of it so why are we prohibiting
people of color and people from lower
socioeconomic communities from entering
this industry so there's a lot of good
that's coming out of the cannabis
industry and then there's also all these
other things we still need to fix yeah
and then so what are some of the may be
the action items that people are taking
away from the film well what's
interesting is when I started the film
the statistic was 36 percent of senior
leadership in cannabis was women and by
the time the film premiered at our first
Festival in the fall of 2017 it had
dropped to 27 and I think that's because
in 2016 we had eight new states come on
board including California and at that
point you've opened the floodgates for
financing well the other industry we saw
a built in our lifetime was the tech
industry and we've got this model that
you take a couple guys in sweatshirts
you give them a computer in a garage and
they build the next app or they build
the next tech company right and so
you've got funders who are used to that
model and they're now looking at
cannabis going I'm gonna fund what I'm
comfortable with so I'm comfortable with
white men who probably have you know a
Harvard or Yale MBA right and that's not
necessarily
the activists who helped bring this
industry forward right typically people
with an MBA have no experience in the
cannabis right so they might they might
know how to pitch a business plan to
investors right or they're really good
at PowerPoint but they may not really
understand the plant or they may not
understand yeah or the communities that
you're gonna go into and sell because
normally if you're looking for a place
to open a dispensary it's going to be in
the lower-income communities right and
that's really loaded for cannabis
businesses who to come into a community
that has been targeted by the police and
there's like but you know we're in
business suits now it's okay to buy from
us and that's a really tricky thing to
navigate and not everybody's sensitive
to that so if they're not hiring and
training you know the local community to
then come in and then mentor them to
work their way up there just profiting
yeah and also inspiring people to be
creative through their cannabis use feel
like that's something that we don't talk
about enough is the consumptive side of
cannabis versus the creative side of
cannabis that's a really important touch
well and it's interesting to be here in
the tech women in tech summit right
because we have a lot of really smart
talented women and male allies who are
here and they've got a lot of great
skills that could benefit or the
cannabis industry could benefit from and
yet there's still some stigma as to who
do I really want to risk my professional
reputation by coming into the cannabis
industry and I get that like especially
for women you know we still bear the
brunt of a lot of the stigma and we have
a lot of the consequences you know if a
father is using cannabis they're not
necessarily gonna have child protection
services called on them but if the
mother uses cannabis even for a medical
like a medical purpose
for an illness or something CPS is
called or it's actually happening yeah
still that's really weird we we just
have this expectation that that's
different for the genders it's
interestingly enough I think that it's
sometimes it almost also enhances your
connection to your child
well cases but I mean we also have
schools who've been calling the police
because there are children who are being
given CBD from their parents you know
maybe it's for epilepsy or autism or
ADHD or something like that but they're
like you've endangered a child and you
give it in like a like a very very small
like right dose or something and it's
really concerned or lack of education so
there's a lot of things we we need to
fix right we also need to fix drug
testing you know because people are
still testing for whether you've used
marijuana in a state where it's legal
and I say are we testing for alcohol are
we testing for all these other hard
drugs you know but they leave your
system a lot faster than cannabis does
so it it's a just a matter of time I
think before there's a class-action
lawsuit from employees who are like you
shouldn't be up in my business you know
I can still have my job whether it's a
blue-collar job or a white-collar job
and I can still do that and go home and
choose cannabis instead of alcohol or
opioids yeah yeah there's also the sort
of a hilarious tech process especially
in start-up world which is that like if
I'm trying to join your team
you'd be like oh cool like show me your
skills and I like show you my skills and
stuff whatever I'm doing and then you're
like great you have the skills welcome
aboard
you know and then it's there's not ever
this stage of like make sure to fill in
all of the bubbles about it's like no
you seem like a very
person you can do your skills that's
what matters
yeah and yet we don't require that for
the stock people the drivers you know
the people the people who are working at
Walmart or Target or you know any of
these other things you know that those
minimum wage jobs are drug tested at a
higher rate and at that point you know I
I think that's racist
it's definitely classist I would also
venture that it's racist yeah it's yeah
yeah so I wonder where cuz I want to
touch on what we just talked about with
classism maybe maybe we should touch on
that right now let's do it okay so where
else is this both within cannabis as
well as what you've mentioned a couple
examples but we I mean we don't talk
about this on the show enough and we
definitely should but we talk about
socio-economic disparity a lot on the
show we talk about potential for wealth
inequality of such severe extremes that
due to extra technology that that we
just have a class-based speciation now
maybe what are your thoughts a little
bit on that and where what are some of
these like solutions that we can provide
like you were describing some like you
know like get get this some drug
checking out of the out of the lowest
sort of minimum wage jobs but at the
same time of course you don't want to
bring on people that are gonna be like
straight up junkie on the job so there's
gotta be some weird sort of like balance
of figuring that out
mmm-hmm what excites me the most about
the cannabis industry is the opportunity
to really tackle the gender wage gap and
wealth inequality radio's because when
women and people of color are able to
build up wealth you know not all of us
come from generational wealth right like
other communities and so if we're able
to build wealth and pay ourselves well
and
hey people who look like us the same
amount for the same work that's a
game-changer in our communities and our
families and our politics everything so
if we value ourselves and we value women
in particular on paper as the same
amount you know it's that idea of like a
woman's a human it's like right
she's also earning the same amount as a
man no matter what the job is they're
paid the same I mean your influence in
your family in your community you're
able to donate to political action
campaigns and candidates and like all
these other things like we become bigger
influencers and that's a game changer in
the United States and it is in the world
you know the two opportunities I see and
hear from women as to why they're coming
to cannabis the first one is they are
able to be the CEO of the company and
create the corporate culture that they
want right so they don't have to be the
senior vice president of something and
having all these dudes that they've
trained get promoted over them right
they get to be the CEO and they get to
hire who they want to work with and what
we see is that when women and people of
color start companies they hire more
women they hire more people of color
they hire more veterans they hire more
people from the LGBTQ community and it's
because we intuitively know that if we
have diverse perspectives we're set up
for success you know if everybody looks
the same and thinks the same you're not
gonna see the obstacle coming at you
right so diversity diversity leads to
greater success and this is true in
cannabis fortune 500 companies film sets
everything the second thing that I see
women do in cannabis is they're able to
create products that fit into their
lifestyle you know women are not
interested in the tallest bong ever
built nor are they interested in the
most THC so they're stuck on the couch
for a week right like and I've actually
been at filming at conferences
is where a man said women are going to
be what saves this industry because if
it wasn't for their presence we would
just have this stoner dude image still
and instead what we're seeing is you
know smaller products more discreet
products something that's gonna fit into
your your lifestyle you know there is
cannabis that you can drop into a cup of
tea nobody needs to know what you're
doing and you're already having a cup of
tea right or they're creating the odor
blocking technology for purses so you
can go pick up your kids or have a
meeting in the boardroom or with the
principal and nobody's gonna know what's
in your bag you know they're creating
all of these different things because
nobody else was going to do it for them
and I will say that that the great
opportunity I see in cannabis is we can
really fix you know these larger
conversations about gender parity you
know women wrote the original computer
programs that built the tech industry
and we saw that happen in our lifetime
and women are now down to 26 percent of
the tech industry so women are now at
the forefront of the next great industry
that we're building in our lifetime
cannabis and we need to make sure the
same thing doesn't happen but we've
already dropped down to 27 percent so I
try to encourage people at film
screenings you know the call to action
has become a lot stronger since the film
has come out it's not necessarily just
look at all the great things women are
doing with now almost a recruitment tool
of like we need you to come in and join
us right and I've heard this great
saying that whatever you did outside of
cannabis you can do inside of cannabis
you just add in cannabis it's kind of
like the old fortune cookie trick right
so you can if you're an event programmer
you're an event programmer in canvas if
you're a filmmaker your film maker in
cannabis if you're a coder or a
programmer or you run a lab you know
like just add in cannabis and that's how
you come in like there's not this glass
ceiling or even the
grass feeling right you can if whatever
you want to do you come on in there's
room for you and all the creativity and
innovation that's coming from that now
you said the odor-blocking purses and
the the small little more discreet way
stone to use cannabis the the grass
[Laughter]
we're full of puns in the cannabis
recently learned uh tell them hi from me
and HR yeah agent said that's so funny
you guys have tons of funds so that this
is really that was a good list of things
that you're really excited about and I'm
sure you've learned a ton for making
this yeah yeah you know I didn't start
out as a cannabis activist but I by the
end of the film I've actually become an
advocate yeah yeah it's an it's an
advocate it's it's is I wonder if if
you're right about the female feminine
energy coming into the equation and
catalyzing less of the stoner dude
culture because really the sooner due to
culture is kind of a culture that I'm
also a little bit like its alienating
you know like I think that's not
productive either the society wants more
creative people that are building cool
things and building cool futures and I
mean if we're just using cannabis as an
escape yeah yeah and I mean I I just
think I had ample opportunity to try
cannabis in my youth right and I never
did because I was like why would I do
that the only people I knew who did that
you know were the stoner dudes in school
right you know and I I admit that I was
judgy in the past because I was like I
have [ __ ] that's just [ __ ] to do sorry
or I have a bunch of stuff to do I don't
know if I can swear on you okay
I've been bleeped before so I'm trying
to keep raining it um you know I had
enough to do and I never really knew
whether it was safe or not so I never
saw myself represented
um in the community so I was just kind
of it was off-putting by what I saw and
now that I am able to see women in the
industry and the products that they're
creating you know by the end of the film
I actually tried cannabis for the first
time ever and that's in the movie and
it's actually a really fun scene
everybody really enjoys it and we have a
little really lively QA after all the
film screenings I don't want to give
away I don't want to give it you got to
see the movie hopefully coming into a
distribution channel near right right
yeah definitely follow us on social and
find us on our website that's how we're
gonna announce things but I mean I took
the opportunity to flip the script you
know I had heard from a lot of women
that the first time that they tried
cannabis somebody passed them something
at a party or maybe their boyfriend
purchased it or there was a lot of peer
pressure in the situation and you know
it wasn't a very consensual or
empowering thing so I figured if I was
going to do this you know in my late 30s
let's change the situation so I went
into a female in minority on dispensary
I spoke to a female budtender I
explained the situation and the
experience that I wanted and they really
helped guide what product that I picked
and then I put a group of cannabis fairy
godmothers together who you know they
were the experts they've been doing this
for years just so I had the those um
like those spirit guides right to really
bring me into the community and it was a
fun empowering you know amazing
experience and I would just love you
know other people who've been curious
but maybe they're not quite sure you
know - I - just take that step to have
the conversation you know whether it's
take your family member who's been
suffering from arthritis into the
dispensary and see what kind of product
they could find or have that
verse a ssin with a friend or a family
member or spouse about how can we use
cannabis to get off all these other
pharmaceuticals that we know are having
bad side effects and for other women you
know I would encourage them to just go
in and figure out as a health and
wellness product how can this fit into
our lifestyle you know you don't have to
get stoned to use cannabis I'm there I
mean I actually great to just do a
little tiny bit well and what I do every
day
it's like micro dosing right right I
mean and and that works for a lot of
people I mean I am now a daily cannabis
user but the way it fits into my
lifestyle is I put topicals on my neck
and shoulders because I've got some old
injuries I put hemp hearts on my yogurt
in the morning you know I'm not puffing
on a vape every day because that doesn't
fit into my lifestyle right but though I
get the benefits of the cannabinoids by
doing those small things and then maybe
on a Friday or a Saturday night I might
take like two point five milligrams of
an edible so you usually like a quarter
of something or I might take a little
puff on on a vape but I don't get to the
point where I feel like I'm out of
control I what I notice is like the
tension from the week just kind of like
slips off my shoulders and I'm like okay
you know I feel like I'm in a hammock in
the Caribbean
happy Friday you know and that's what
fits into my lifestyle but I also know
that I am privileged because I don't
have any children so they're not gonna
get taken away from me I don't have a
job where I'm gonna be drug tested you
know I'm my own boss I don't live
anywhere that is going to prohibit me
from using cannabis you know I'm not in
public housing or things like that so
I'm hopefully using my position of
privilege to help have the these other
conversations that we need to have you
know and several states we've legalized
right so we may not be putting people in
jail for using it anymore but there's
still all these other things we have to
fix man
just a sheer amount of information that
you've been teaching so far it's just
been so interesting in that then you
think you know you know I know like 1%
about everything and that you're talking
about net that's that that speaks like
to me Wow why do I not know more about
this it's this it's the stigma right
like people haven't come out of the
green closet yet you know and I think
it's happening more the more and more
yeah when those puns we have um but I
mean when I parents don't want to hear
you say it in many cases you know
co-workers definite I had people
unfriend me on LinkedIn when I announced
that I was gonna do this film because
they didn't want to be professionally
associated with somebody who would do a
film about cannabis and I was like all
right we'll see how long it takes before
you come back and now you know three
years later it's like oh who's having a
successful bride of a film you know you
want to come back in a month
hmm I don't really remember you you know
who are you
I don't we go yeah it's a huge change in
philosophy and culture it's also all the
things that you were teaching or you
know the gender disparity and also the
social justice side of things is just so
mind-expanding to be able to learn about
it and really figure out kind of what's
next for figuring out how to just make a
tighter knit social fabric and I think
we're on our way with things like the
women in tech summit as well as what
you're producing with Mary Jane yeah now
maybe we asked you a question about you
know we've talked about this a little
bit but let's ask you more directly what
is a good way to maximize the potential
of women as well as young women in the
world stop under estimating us I mean
that happens all the time just based on
your gender I mean it happens before you
even meet people sometimes based on your
name you know like what's the name on
the resume that comes through the desk
you know or the signature at the bottom
of an email it doesn't matter what I'm
saying but based on my name they're like
mmm that's probably a female gender um
at this point in my career I find it
amusing when people less underestimate
me I was like you're gonna be really
surprised when you find out what I'm
capable of right but it was really it's
really frustrating
you know and fundraising for films I've
even had to prove why it was important
to do a film about women in cannabis you
know I had a female funder ask me why do
a film about women and I was like where
50% the population were 33% of speaking
roles in films and they're leading this
new industry why wouldn't I do a film
about women she obviously didn't fund
the movie and I had to have you know
massage my answer a little bit so I
wasn't so snarky but I'm just proving
that we were worth it right stop
underestimate yeah and and the other
thing I would encourage women to do is
one of the most courageous things we can
do is tell our stories yeah okay it can
also get men to be vulnerable and tell
their stories too well I'll take it a
step further because history loves to
write out the women the people of color
and the LGBTQ community and say nope
just the straight white cisgendered men
did all of this and it's like you didn't
do it in a vacuum you know we were here
too and we so if this film really became
important to document history as it was
happening and to show these are just a
fraction of the women who were involved
in building a socially responsible
cannabis industry you know and we didn't
have a word for it when we started so
there's all these cute words to talk
about women in in canvas like conjugals
and like green goddesses and he's like
all these other things and it's like
that doesn't work do their work justice
I think so we have a Jameses
it's pretty good but we ended up
creating the word puff for jet ya puffer
JA
so it's pot Plus suffragette and we
define a
huh Fredette as a woman or a man who's
building gender parity social justice
and environmental sustainability into
the cannabis industry thank you yes
so we created a word and we created a
logo so and we've you know trademarked
both of them so we can help carry this
forward and it's been really exciting to
see women and men at film screenings
come about for jet I was like great
everyone can be one come on in yeah here
we go into the future right into this
puffer jet culture yeah it's the puffer
jet movement yeah thank you for
embarking on it this is huge thank you
thanks for taking this major risk and
also this this tougher it's a tougher
fuel to enter into it's not one that's
more safe you would like you said people
unfriended you know I'm it was more
difficult to raise money but you're
you're embarking on at the edge and
they're just amazing you're welcome
I've never shied away from you know
tackling tough topics but they've been
about you know elephants and Thailand or
just Lexia or you know these other
things that people were it was more
palatable for communities or film
festivals right like they're not
everybody's ready to talk about cannabis
in their community yet but when they are
the conversation just grows Mary Jane's
will be at the forefront of the of the
films that are then introduced to them
yeah I hope so
so how about we ask you a couple of the
quick questions on the way I think one
more okay well they gotta get to the
Train let's do speed around that okay
speed around all right what is the most
beautiful thing in the world a woman
stepping into her power and finding your
voice yeah heck yes
yeah okay and then do you think we're
alone in the cosmos I don't think we
could be but I think we're screwing up
this planet enough that other people are
watching and being or other beings are
watching and going like we're not gonna
go there and touch that yet and then
what about do you think we're in a
simulation
well the singularity is near if it's not
already here right so I think it's
entirely possible I do like the idea of
you know the the Buddhist idea of we're
all just dreaming the same dream and we
need to wake up so I kind of take that
tact more than tennis simulations but
it's anything's possible when do you
thank you so much thank you such a
pleasure really appreciate it
really looking forward to see Mary Jane
really looking forward to seeing it
Allen theaters will have a link in the
bio Thanks distribution channels as well
social links below if you guys had a
good time make sure to go share the
content with other people go and talk
about it was to subscribe and comment
below with your thoughts also I do go
create something with this go and have
more conversations about women about
women in cannabis and about the
importance of social justice and gender
disparity no gender parity and then also
join us on patreon help us out help us
get this content out to more people and
do more cool productions at places like
the women and tech summit so thanks
everyone for tuning in and we'll talk to
you soon
you